as we mentioned earlier the invention
and inspiration for deep compositing can
be shared among several individuals our
next recipients are responsible for the
development prototyping and promotion of
early advancement of workflow
technologies pretty deep compositing
these include layering and a holdout
order independence spatial and intra
element correction keep paying attention
and post render depth of field in fact
their techniques have revolutionized
workflow between lighting and effects
Department effects departments for early
advancements in deep compositing the
Academy presents a technical achievement
award to Collin Doncaster johannes some
are yato a Chavarria jana
comes Canon and Chris Cooper so as
mentioned this was a huge contribution
for many people and what I love about
the deep compositing technology is that
it really shows that multiple people
converged on the same great idea as
there's people from various studios up
here in various countries you know we
all got together as an industry and and
jumped on that great idea it
standardized it and started adopting it
rather than patenting it in sort of
suing everyone so I think it's really
important that that the industry can
continues that way on top of that I'd
love to thank my beautiful wife Kirsten
or two boys and my parents and my late
father-in-law for this wonderful boat I
thank you
I would like to thank you Academy it
still feels really really unreal to be
able to say this and as everybody said
before we are just here as an as an
example for coming up with this idea of
deep image compositing and there were
lots of enthusiastic artists all along
the way it made this possible and I
really want to say a thanks to everybody
who was giving us the the possibility to
work with them all along the way being
up here I really want to thank my
parents who have always been a huge part
in supporting my passion for visual
effects and recently I was able to
extend my family all the way to
Australia and I want to thank my new
family especially my beautiful wife
Simone who is my true passion thank you
Wow I'd like to thank the Academy in the
side tech committee I also want to thank
what a digital for believing in me and
in particular Jolla Terry for being such
an inspirational and visionary leader
dr. Peter Hillman for taking our idea
and turning it into an amazing tool set
I like to thank all my collaborators up
here on the stage this evening I really
believe that collaboration is the heart
and soul of filmmaking and I also want
to thank all the compositors around the
world who thought that deep compositing
was a good idea and now using it on a
daily basis and lastly I just want to
say I'm very very proud to be a part of
the ongoing story of the history of
filmmaking thank you
well this is a great honor and I'd like
to thank the Academy for acknowledging
our work and I'd also like to thank my
colleagues Johanneson : who and took
some my early ideas and develop them in
new and interesting ways and I'd like to
thank my employer at the time Animal
Logic and my current employer NICTA and
also my family my beautiful wife here
solver and I'd also just like to thank
my college ray tracing lecturer having
having a student received this award has
made him a very proud old man so Thank
You Academy for the award this is a
great great honor run in ten days I'll
be 40 years old so what a birthday
presents relief since I'm the one
representing green roofs on this award I
need to thank a short list of people I
want to recognize Thomason and Mark
Davis and Patrick Kelly for the Richards
and development of deep images in
DreamWorks Animation the initial push
for better compositing in DreamWorks
came from Yancey linguist
who was the head of effects for the
movie monsters vs. aliens
in fact I wanna thank all the talented
amazingly talented artists in dreamers
who push the boundaries of this
technology and still do and when I
thanked the dreamers seemed for they
worked during the Academy interviews and
I want to thank my former manager Andrew
Coons and the director of R&D Andrew
peers who believed in to this technology
from the beginning and also thanks to
the whole studio for being a place
that's willing to take risks and try
things that nobody has really tried
before it's really a big deal and
finally I want to thank my wife Caterina
for her lab and support I couldn't wish
for anything more Thank You host thank
you everybody thank you